oh oh it's so Sunny up here
there goes my hero
I think he's gonna be oh no oh
no oh Jessica why'd you choose to see oh
I didn't why'd you choose this seat it
could have been any other scene he's
like what whoa
that is a long Quiet Flight Home on the
back of vegar
I would I'm so mad why did you start
with that one I mean that was the most
shocking moment I hate that nobody has
not been able to read
there's other season for this episode we
could have watched but they were so true
why don't we watch the first five
minutes
oh my God
oh my God how
stillborns I think
three I think we see it we see like four
childbirth scenes in this show we get
the very first one we get lainus
and then we get Rainer two from renera
and two yeah that's four babies four
baby birth scenes one baby making it
baby babies are hard having babies is
tough in Westeros it's tough stuff
welcome back to New Rockstar
welcome back you guys it's the end of
the road for season one of House of the
dragon and it's time to see how Rainer
reacts to everything that happened in
King's Landing last week this episode
has the equivalent of nerves of like
uncut gems from yes a minute to right as
soon as those the beginning intro
credits end to the very last second I
was on the edge of my seat uh oh my God
what will be the actions that black
queen that the black queen takes well we
may have to wait until season two to
find out which kind of sucks but if you
gives you time to read the book and then
we can talk more about it offline uh
this is a big question presents talking
dragons our weekly fantasy after show
I'm Jessica clemency with Brandon Berry
I like Jessica who said we could talk
about it offline to everyone out there
who we'd have to talk to online about it
no no they could tweet me tweet me come
to my house yeah we'll eat some cheese
leave some cheese don't bring up cheese
uh we're gonna talk about the last
episode
House of the Dragon season one We're Not
Gonna spoil anything that's coming up uh
we'll talk about things that happen in
the book leading up to this moment we'll
talk about things that happen in Game of
Thrones much later on in the timeline
you've all already seen and I'm sure uh
but we're gonna keep this as spoiler
free as possible uh to talk about the
end of the season I can't believe the
end of the season is already here it's
so sad and it's maybe two years before
we get the next thing you want to talk
about it they better be filming tomorrow
I genuinely was like I was thinking I
was like do you think they shot like an
episode 11 just in case just in case
just in case I want to throw it in there
really quick just to start things up
kind of like uh Sandman that kind of
really sets Surprise episode yeah they
were like they have a surprise episode
11. well they remember that they did get
this episode leaked and they were very
pissed about it so maybe they're like
we're not gonna give you that episode
yeah yeah because you guys are bad boys
uh we are bad boys uh so let's dive into
the final episode of Season one The
Black Queen we open on luceris examining
the spot of drift mark on the painted
table in Dragonstone uh much more about
this table later he he's worried about
taking over as lord of the tides don't
worry my guy you're never going to be
lord of the time why would you say that
that's not funny that's not something
reminds him okay it's his duty and in
time he will learn to accept it she also
has a good point here about like Destiny
chooses us we don't get to choose our
destiny oh boy uh rhaenice arrives and
bring brings word of viserys's death she
skips the pleasantry and gets right to
the point aegon has been crowned King uh
this news brings pain to a pregnant
rhaenyra who realizes she's now in labor
even though the maesters think it's way
too early and she kind of knows it I
love how from the moment that the news
comes she just immediately like doubles
over it yeah
it was affected it was afflicted Damon
immediately assumes viserys was killed
and goes into war mode he moves to
protect the island with their meager
forces uh he even wants the dragon
Keepers to defend as they're capable
Fighters I love that like the dragon
Keepers know how to fight put him out
there with their pitchforks let's go uh
all the wire all the while rhaenyra is
calling out for him uh in labor pains
you can hear her in the room with the
painted table or he's like trying to
strategize she's calling for him and he
can hear it just ignoring it remember
we're near as biggest fear was like
childbirth she watched her mother die or
didn't watch it but her mother died
during childhood she was always afraid
of having kids she had a few
successfully at this point but now she
knows something's wrong she's pushing
off the nurses she's like no I'll do it
myself and like really it's like she
can't be pregnant right now she's like
this is the one time yeah like I need to
be cool right now now is not the time
and like normal labor is like what like
12 hours and she's just like I'm gonna
push this [ __ ] out too she's watching me
and everyone's like watching me and
she's like no we're good let me help get
away from me get away from him yeah grab
that baby by the head like a basketball
pulls it out I genuinely was like
hardcore hardcore metal as hell I was
like last woman I'm gonna mess with it
was gross you're out of your mind okay
so ranera brings her kids up to speed
while in the pain of childbirth she
reminds to Sarah's that she's still in
charge despite how Damon feels about the
situation because he is ignoring her at
that table that lights up like a little
light break
Damon wants to check in on the Loyalty
of their bannermen as well as their
local Kings guard in the presence of
caraxis uh an interesting lesson for
just Sirius yeah yeah he's like I'll
show you what loyalty is all about uh
this is I think this is very important
for just Sarahs to see though like the
dragons they rule yeah and I mean he
took that to heart later on when he's
like they will obey us with our dragons
didn't didn't think a massive Dragon
would have to go up against you uh David
makes it to renera just in time to see
that their child did not survive it
Rainer does the work of the silent
sisters herself preparing the child for
the afterlife rapping the little baby up
a funeral has had a funeral is held for
the child with all the residents of
Dragonstone present I did like the kind
of juxtaposition of like this funeral
from the one her mom's uh yeah the one
in episode one with like another wrapped
up little baby that didn't serve well
they also have like a grown woman this
one's like a newborn so you could just
throw it in a little little pile of
sticks you know
what the baby's not alive okay anyways
uh don't edit that part out don't need
people to know about me and babies and
then and just then Eric with an E uh he
arrives the twin you remember him yeah
Eric Cargill he has viserys's Crown he
stole it and is here to give it to
rhaenyra and swear his loyalty to her
Damon crownser and everyone present
Niels except for rainey's good old
Rainey Rainey said I don't have weight
can I talk to my husband first give me a
second yeah yeah leave me out of this
but also I like that like his speech I
didn't know that they maybe I just
haven't been paying attention that much
that that whole speech of like I will
never wife I will not have children I
will do nothing because I will keep your
secrets and I will be with you alongside
you till I die that's The kingsguard Oaf
is like yeah I from this moment on I
won't get married I don't have kids I'm
here for you because the idea being that
like a kingsguard can't have these other
things and he's worried about they need
to be worried about the king uh yeah I
love renise doesn't renice doesn't bow
which which is interesting because like
or when Corliss was out before right
she's like I'll take over I'm the boss
let's go but this is like a great thing
of like well Corliss is in charge of the
Navy I'll wait until see what he says I
also love that rhaenis is in a unique
position where again she's at a crowning
ceremony where she where she's the queen
that never was right she sees yet
another person get crowned she's also
the only one to see how both Allison and
raniera react to the death of viserys
right she is this kind of like she sees
how both sides react to the situation
which I think is very interesting uh
that beautiful painted table is prepared
for war they turn on the lights adorable
do you think Stannis Baratheon ever knew
that you know like numbers underneath
absolutely not Gary I can guarantee you
he did it very helpful I mean it was
such a cool effect that kind of gave it
away in the trailer for this episode uh
but it was really cool seeing it all lit
up like that uh raniera and Damon jockey
for control uh they both kind of have
their own ideas of how things should go
uh Damon is very happy to list off their
dragon superiority you know it gets
brought up like hey you guys have
dragons why don't you just go deal with
this and Damon's like yeah we do have
dragons we learned that there are a few
unclaimed dragons at Dragonstone and
most importantly laner's old Dragon sea
smoke is still back a drift Mark I
thought it would already be a
Dragonstone but no it's still back at
driftmark that makes sense so according
to Damon the blacks have 13 dragons to
the greens four uh we'll update that
number in a little bit uh
we're near it Rainier is quick to point
out that none of the blacks dragons have
ever seen more like the only really War
dragon out there right now is vegard
which is it's stupid not to be mean uh
oh no nevermind it's not stupid she
meant Her Dragons the blacks are her
house Instagram because I was like she's
like yeah we have all these dragons but
they're like have not seen battle yet I
love that lineup we don't know how
they're going to react out there I love
that that line has been brought up twice
because if we remember from like the
very I think it was the second episode
where they were doing the jousting and
they were like that was the first
episode when they were like yeah these
boys haven't seen my voice acting crazy
yeah these like Knights they're pretend
fighting all the time and so they're
happy to like bludgeon each other at a
friendly joust uh Otto Ohio Tower
arrives at Dragonstone and in
juxtaposition to earlier in the season
when he showed up at Dragonstone to face
off with Damon uh he and Damon meet on
that same Bridge they kind of have like
the exact same positioning raniera uh
flies down on Cyrax and lands in the
same place kind of cutting them off it's
a very interesting juxtaposition to what
we had seen before or Auto has an offer
pledge obesiance to aegon and raniera
can keep Dragonstone and her heirs can
take drift Mark and have a place in the
court
Otto is basically like we have The High
Ground all the small folks they saw this
you love this you want to be a little
servant
your children could be cup bearings
you drink you wouldn't sip sip before
you gave to Papa delicious don't even
try it aegon's wearing the conquerors
crowd he's got black fire the septums
were there a dragon came out of the
floor but no one cares it was great it
was fine it was totally successful I got
a green dragon on my ship oh we pumped
you
I don't think she has it all Otto little
[ __ ]
he thinks it got it all Rainier is
basically like give me the night to
think about it also she took that hand
shoes yeah when
Otto turns to the maester after that uh
and it's and he pulls out the the paper
from the book I thought he was gonna
pull out another
one
I genuinely thought the Mazer is gonna
unravel it just put another like I was
prepared I also have another one of them
throw them all in the sea he's gonna sir
Kristen Cole Super Single I genuinely
thought the exact same thing but then
when it wasn't I was like honestly thank
God because that's too comedic that
would have been too comical uh Damon is
pissed that raniera is not moving
quickly or aggressive enough in this
situation but she is not eager to make
the first move that would plunge the
Roman to war she doesn't want to be that
person she's like her father she wants
kind of to keep the piece of the realm
together because she knows about aegon's
dream rhaenyra soon discovers that Damon
doesn't know about this dream has no
idea what the Song of Ice and Fire is
and he responds aggressively when
confronted with that choking her I mean
that was intense uh he never liked
viserys's Omens and portends as he puts
it he says quote dreams didn't make us
Kings dragons did hmm but viserys feels
a certain way about those dragons he
always has also that scene was like I
genuinely and I'm sure I'm like a lot of
people watching maybe not that was like
oh my God but they love each other like
they love each other they love each
other and then when I saw this scene I
was like I need to remember that Damon's
not a good character Damon's not a good
guy remember he's violent and he's
aggressive and he's hot-headed and of
course that stuff will translate into
their marriage eventually and it's
starting here we're seeing it already
like she is the queen he is not the king
like he needs to recognize like whatever
she says goes and he's like well she
doesn't know I'm older than her I should
have got it and I'm like oh God remember
when Damon was in the stepsons and he
got the message from his brother that
like hey I'm coming to help he beat the
messenger to death yeah like he's he is
hot-headed yeah he is very temperamental
and very dangerous and I do not like him
as much as I like game on I switched him
I've switched from him to Eamon but not
anymore
okay so rainey's and Corliss finally
reunite
unikes up and I was like
look at my man he's like oh I've whipped
boys for falling asleep on the watch and
she's like she said she said that I was
like this is exactly how I'd react I'd
be like oh jokes huh oh joke jokes do
you know what I was six years you know
what I was doing yeah you you laughing
it up sleeping in that bed like viserys
you dead man anyways brain is as pissed
he abandoned her as I would be too I
know that it was like his sickness but
still I was left with a lot she tells
him about Damon Corliss says they shall
declare for No One But Raines reminds
them that their grandchildren will
always be a threat from aegon Corliss
who's been gone for six years sick
almost dies wakes up and it's like oh
don't worry honey we're just gonna
forget all this and live on our live on
drift Mark and she's like you [ __ ]
idiot we lost every we only have two
family members left your brother's dead
like we and then on top of that they're
now connected to the person that we
think killed our son why are you waking
up saying we're just gonna run away it's
all going to be yeah she's like your
brother's dead and he's like oh oh she's
like well you tried to take your crown
and he also called your grandchildren
bastards and he was like okay he said
well he was always he said what we
always are temperamental
it was so such a fast brush I don't need
to avenge it you mean my brother oh okay
oh okay yeah yeah I don't know I like
him do we have his body okay so
rhaenerys uh raineries also points out
that rhaenera is the only I hate that
their names are so close rhaenys also
points out that rhaenyra is the only one
keeping a level head which is true and
thus the realm is a relative place of
Peace which like her dad she's doing a
good job yeah except for Damon's being a
dick about it later at the painted table
Corliss supports rhaenyra's claim and
Bows he reveals that he Now controls the
stepstones and that they can create a
blockade to King's Landing reynus is
happy to help with melees I love that
like for all we've heard of the triarchy
we saw a little bit of their fighting
finally it's open the triarchy is gone
it's like okay great I'm sure they'll be
back again yeah you guys can never get
rid of them he's like no this time we
built a Garrison this might be safe now
my favorite and least favorite thing
about this series is knowing Game of
Thrones and and being like well okay uh
you guys aren't gonna live my life
rings of power when they were at numenor
I was like okay okay enjoy the city
folks it's gorgeous for now uh the kids
fly to Aaron Stark and Baratheon to
check on their allegiances rhaenyra
makes Luke and Jace swear Rainer makes
Luke and Jay swear on the seven that
they won't fight just deliver messages
like bring the book we didn't see the
book off screen and she's like swear on
the book and they're like we don't even
believe it also it's like I'm I mean
yeah I mean sorry to spoil this you guys
Luke wasn't going to survive even if he
was given the right to fight
amen let Luke fight yeah let please of
all the the targaryens I love how Luke
was like yeah I don't find a promise
it's like all right buddy we just saw
you get your ass kicked on the beach
Yeah Yeah by your brother and they said
go easy go easy on it when they said go
easy I was okay I'll say that to Sir
Krista gold when he's punching my head
in either way she makes them swear on
the seven that they won't fight just
deliver the messages Lucas clearly
scared shitless and we know he is
because since the beginning he's been
like I don't want to do this and before
mother tells him that uh she suspects he
will receive a very warm welcome
I'm very I'm sure you'll get a very warm
welcome at storms in and then I that
this is the thing about the show we read
the book so we know a lot of the
spoilers we know how it goes and I still
fall for it every time I genuinely am
like I think it's that's just the the
perks of media and like entertainment
this is like it gets you to love people
it gets you to love people no matter
what even the book didn't do it that
well and I was like oh I love this kid
he's not gonna die anytime soon
did we so Damon goes to check on an
unclaimed dragon in the dragon mount
that big volcano he sings a sweet little
song at high Valerian so adorable and
this dragon is vermouth or vermouth
Verma Thor I thought it was
you say your words so this is the former
Dragon of King joharis the conciliator
uh this was Damon's grandfather also
viserys's grandfather he was the one we
saw at the very beginning of the season
the old man who had to decide who would
who had the great counsel to decide who
would be the next this is and this is
his Dragon who no one claimed after he
died and this one is just as like big
yeah so this is like a burial Dragon
over 100 years old and it's the second
biggest dragon after Veigar oh yeah so
so and we see you see the scar on it
snap like this dragon has seen fights
the Breath of Fire it held it for like a
full minute and I said yeah you really
gonna you're really gonna try to try to
steal this
I love the eye
I hate how uh I hate vegar but I love
vegar at the same time because like I'm
just old as hell I'm just old as hell
who is that what did I just eat
what's happening where am I
sit with me on the beach all right stop
so good our good little boy Lucero shows
up on to Storm's end on air ax his cute
tiny little dragon it is baby uh and he
discovers vegar is already there looming
over the walls which means amond is
there as well
I know I would have just left I would
have left dude my job his mom said I'm
on a job Boris Baratheon is amused by
the strange jacking for positioning and
House Targaryen uh he receives runnier's
message via luceris but we also learned
that our boy boros can't read uh little
Leah Michelle action oh Boris Baratheon
can't read I guess I don't know he's
like we're at the Macer also he's
putting a lot of trust in this maester
to tell him what's on this piece of
paper also uh Leah come on the show and
tell us you can't read damn it stops
it's not funny girl
it's clear that boros is already Team
Green like he is not even playing nice
here he's like I'm not interested in
this he goes who's gonna marry my yeah
well England is promised to Wed one of
boris's daughter a lovely little brother
ethium the dark-haired girl in exchange
for his loyalty Luke cannot do the same
he's already promised uh to Reina he's
going to marry her uh his cousin or sis
cousin sister step sister I don't know
they are related not by Blood but oh I
guess not well
no not by Blood because they're not
they're not laners at all but like by
marriage anyways
they're technically related uh so so he
can't do the same he's already with
trust right uh he's also so Boris is
also insulted by Redner's message which
is basically like remember what your dad
promised and Boris was like I'm the man
now I can't read
uh before Lucas is able to leave though
Eamon wants one of Luke's eyes as
payment for his own he shows us his cute
little sapphire eyes got in there and
blue eyes white man and this positioning
is very interesting because remember
this is where a young renira went when
she was like meeting suitors and that's
where we saw a baby Blackwood uh cut
open an older boy right so it's like oh
are we gonna have the same fight happen
we're gonna have this older versus
younger fight is this mean little Luke
can put up a fight I don't think so uh
and Boris is like no fighting in my
house this guy came here as an Envoy
he's protected I won't have this Blood
spilled here
so Luke tries to leave and Eman gives
Pursuit on vegar and we see just how
much bigger vegar is than little baby
Eric's the dragons appear to ignore
their Riders which is very important
here Eric tries to put up a little fight
which pisses off Vega both the time like
you know Luke's like no no and anyone's
like no no no but they kind of fight
each other and luceris is just ripped
from the skies eaten by Veigar and
Eric's is gone as well so we're down a
kid Dino Dragon uh rhaenyra is not
pleased when she hears the new she again
doubles she nearly doubles over in pain
she feels it immediately uh just kind of
like we saw at the beginning of the
episode when she got bad news she turns
to face the camera Ready for War and
this is a shot nearing the end of the
shot in episode one where we saw a
younger when you're turned around to
face the people who had just pledged our
oath to them uh and now she's turning it
around again and she is definitely not
playing around anymore she's lost the
thing no children in this episode the
dance of the Dragons has begun I never
even book wise uh
I'm never Avenged for Luke Luke and then
also like in the which we might get into
later in the book they said there are so
many like what it could have been it was
like three routes it was like people
were like oh he fell off the dragon he's
actually alive and now he's just like
weird and crazy and no one knows who he
is there's so many different stories how
did they figure out that he died how did
Damon figure out so quickly I assume
that unless it's been a day or two yeah
I said that Damon just by the fact that
we know it's close remember it's a quick
Dragon ride he doesn't come back I would
also assume maybe Damon went to go check
real fast and found pieces do you think
Damon followed oh that's but then just
watched and just well I think he would
have intervened well actually I don't
think he wouldn't because it's like
vegar is beggar right you saw how
vegar's literal like canine teeth was
the biggest through that tiny dragon I
don't know well we'll get into all that
but first we want to remind you to check
out new rockstarsmerch.com where there's
still time to grab our latest Obsession
shirt Ashton ruin inspired by house of
the Dragon this limited edition shirt
won't be available for much longer so be
sure to grab one before it's devoured in
the Sky by an angry vagar stop making
those jokes check out all the great
merch options we have over at New
rockstarsmerch.com okay Jessica let's
get into this one all right because this
was a great end to the season there's so
much more to come uh so many questions
left uh but I think we've got to address
like the big question we have right now
was viserys actually the dreamer that he
always wanted to be because I think
we've seen a lot of his prophecies come
true okay we had the early on remember
he told in the first episode he tells
his wife Emma I see I'm gonna have a son
and he's gonna be wearing the conquerors
crown and I was like hahaha it was not
birthed that way uh he's not birthed at
all it doesn't survive the baby doesn't
survive but we now have a son of viserys
wearing the conquerors Crown sitting on
the throne so that prophecy has kind of
come true right and now I think the
biggest prophecy we need to remember
here is in the first episode uh when
viserys is talking to a young renira and
they're at the the skull of uh boleron
the black black dread and he says quote
the idea that we control the dragons is
an illusion there are power man never
should have trifled with one that
brought Valeria its Doom
we see here how Amendment and uh joserus
both don't or luceros I apologize both
aren't unable to control their dragons
uh Eamon says it in both English and
high valarian like no no obey me like
listen to me and they don't uh and this
whole Dance of the Dragons is gonna get
set off by literal dragons it's up to
the dragons to fight and so you know I
think for saris is true he was also
right about the step Stones remember
when yeah he did not want to get
involved with the war the triarchy he's
like it's going to be a problem blah
blah blah and Damon was like no we need
to go in there we can wipe this out cut
to four years later and they have this
like long drawn out war in the
stepstones it's still not resolved they
get that resolved and then it kicks up
again and it almost gets Corliss killed
like viserys was right about a lot of
things the thing which is uh it's like
okay so I will first say I do think he's
a dreamer I saw this in the last episode
right but I also think his dreams are
very vague it's like yeah the Chan like
if gambling's real he's like my son will
wear a crown you have 12 of sons so it's
like you're given yes zero okay I'm just
saying in the future you're probably
gonna have a lot of kids and your kids
will have kids and those kids will have
kids so technically by proxy you have
like 12 40 kids right
um and then the same goes for like yeah
it's like they're gonna be our downfall
yeah they're dragons that's like being
like
God is gonna be our downfall but that's
a big thing for I mean but in that in
that uh uh example you just made Jessica
that would be like saying that would be
like the pope saying that God is going
to be our downfall yeah it's like yeah
of course the Targaryen
what maybe uh the targaryens their whole
thing is dragons it's their house
sigilant it's their it's what they
believe in they see themselves as like
Gods almost you know Rainier kind of
brings that up here like they they have
different gods like they see things
totally differently so for viserys to be
like dragons are our main problem that's
like a wild thing for a Targaryen to say
right it's wild but it's like it's it's
been true and I'm sure the first person
I'm sure the first person was like this
is probably a bad idea but like being
able to conquer one does make you like
their whole bloodline is just egos is
just like we deserve this and we want it
and we're gonna get it because we have
dragons and it's like yeah of course
something that's a loose cannon is going
to be your downfall I'm sure the first
guy that did it in your family was like
this is dangerous like there's been a
lot of maesters or the whatevers that
die from handling these dragons but I
think I don't think that he's not a
dreamer I said in the last breakdown or
the last of our podcast that I was like
I believe him I believe that there are
people our dreamers and I think the
dreamers are the ones that are
notoriously never on Dragon back like
he's definitely a dreamer and that makes
me think I wish he had interacted more
with Helena because it's it's clear
they're setting up I think they should
be a dreamer and if maybe he was talking
with her he could have been like hey we
should listen to Helena here well to us
we're like clearly she's something but
to them they're probably like she's just
a little off she's a little cuckoo and
the show established that he didn't
really interact with his other kids
right aegon's always like do you love me
Daddy and he's like I don't know who you
are
veneer is my only child my love that's a
bad thing right you should have been
paying more attention to this because I
think it would have been helpful uh and
I mean all of these ideas that he's a
dreamer if Allison really takes that to
heart you know he had that speech with
her at the bonfire at the hunt like I'm
a dreamer and he lays it all out that's
her thing where she's like well I have
to do what he says he said aegon's the
prince that was promised she's getting
it wrong but still no one has corrected
no and not even correct I don't need I
don't need these only getting corrected
I just want them to be like well there's
another one they may gone I just want
that I just want that question that said
and brought to you as soon as they say
well what about my son aegon like then
I'll be like okay good yeah at least
someone brought it up but when I was on
the bridge and he's like oh the king
changed his mind even we're near it's
like okay yeah right she has the same
reaction that everyone had to Alice hit
last episode but now since like the king
changed his mind and they're all like
yeah sure okay also when
um also the greens have some balls I
keep showing up here so a place riddled
with dragons no like they're so lucky
right now as a nice person because if it
was just Damon I'd be like you guys
can't show up well in a way you know I
think
Otto and the greens they're trying to
provoke Rainier to act oh absolutely
because she won't look like a rebellious
thing like dangerous person coming in on
a dragon causing all this drama like
they kind of want her to react because
they want her to start 100 more so that
they can finish it 100 and also they
need I think we talked about this before
they need as much bad like just
recognition that Rainier is the bad one
they're the good one because right now
their King is known for having a bunch
of children and forcing them to fight in
a ring and assaulting a lot of people so
this news with Eamonn not being able to
control vegar which I'm sure he's never
gonna translate to Allison and Otto
being like no he didn't listen to me
like he's never gonna say that is
another Mark of like great now you
slayed like the princess's son right you
idiot we look horrible so I hope that's
how season two starts out back up and
it's like 100 on purpose I will pitch it
right now I'm not gonna put money on it
season two episode one Allison slaps the
[ __ ] out that's what we're gonna see
she's gonna start training she's gonna
start treating him like because oh my
God can you but you saw his face he's
like holy [ __ ] I just killed yeah like
he's very and he's he's the well now the
coral is back I don't think so but he
was supposed to be he was going to be
Mark of um
he never
oh yeah well we have a lot more to talk
about so many more questions but first
we want to thank our sponsors for our
show today uh sponsors like a vast
hopefully we'll never have to worry
about someone stealing the throne right
from underneath us but one thing we do
have to worry about is cyber crime
thankfully Avast is a global leader in
cyber protection for more than 30 years
and trusted by millions of users they
prevent over 1.5 billion attacks every
month way to go Avast a vast new
all-in-one solution a vast one helps you
take control of your safety and privacy
online through a range of features a
vast free version includes all the
essential features such as free
antivirus free VPN and free firewall
protection but a vast premium version
has even more advanced protection and
allows you to protect multiple devices a
vast multitude of features provides you
with privacy and security as you scour
the web and even help your machine's
performance I personally like their
award-winning antivirus that stops
viruses and malware from harming my
devices as well as their data breach
monitoring that will alert me if my
online accounts have ever been
compromise which is really nice because
companies don't like to do that they
don't like to admit they were
compromised but a best one will do that
for you and their ransomware protection
also secures my personal photos
documents and other files from being
modified modified deleted or encrypted
by ransomware attacks thanks to Avast
for supporting big question today
confidently take control of your online
world with a vast one it helps you stay
safe from viruses phishing attacks
ransomware hacking attempts and other
cyber crimes learn more about Avast one
at avast.com we also want to thank one
tree for sponsoring the show today go
deeper into the canals of numenor the
minds of Kaza doom and more with the
official Lord of the Rings the rings of
power podcast host Felicia Day and
several special guests provide an inside
look at the groundbreaking series at
what it took to bring Middle Earth to
life each episode of the official
podcast features exclusive interviews
with the series showrunners JD Payne and
Patrick McKay including the very first
full breakdown of the incredible season
finale Alicia also goes behind the
scenes with the cast and crew to bring
you jaw-dropping stories and Easter eggs
you won't want to miss watch the rings
of power on Prime video and listen to
all all eight episodes of the official
the Lord of the Rings the rings of power
podcast for free on Amazon music
download the Amazon music app right now
okay Jessica another question for you
today will amen take responsibility for
killing luceras I think we kind of
Define responsibility he's gonna show
back up he's gonna be like I didn't yes
he's not gonna admit that like I didn't
have control of vegar yeah I think he
okay so I think he'll uh because Eamon
is a very
what happened was very dumb
it wasn't there to kill no he wasn't and
I know he knows that's going to cause a
lot he knows that's not that would be
horrible for them especially because for
a man that wants to be king how are you
gonna make because he's technically he's
a Kinsler he's a kinslayer now so he's
never gonna be king now this is what Ray
niece did not want to do when I you know
even Damon was like you didn't burn them
all alive when they're right there like
being a kinslayer is a bad bad thing is
a horrible thing as Eamon loves to point
out he's the uncle here right and like
him killing his nephew especially a
nephew who is sent as an Envoy you know
diplomatic purposes was not provoked you
know uh boom honestly
um
good for Runner but also bad for Redford
bad for an era But ultimately like
politically wise are they ever up up now
they're up in points well now you bring
this up in the book right there's we
don't really know what happens the book
is unreliable narrators there's
different like yeah he either died he
fell off his dragon or he disappeared or
he was killed by uh Eamon on purpose the
only two people there were aemond and
luceris right yeah so and lucerius
cannot speak to what happened so it's
all going to be eamon's account or
someone that saw it lose because Luke
got to the part of the clouds or it's
not storming we got above the storm we
got above the storm and then he's gonna
fall to the ground and if it's a short
distance there is someone that could
have seen something and I'm assuming
that I until we see it next season I'm
like I'm assuming that uh Damon saw it
because how the hell unless it's been a
couple days unless it's been a couple
days we don't know the time but it's
like that was so quick okay so either
way will Emma take responsibility I
think he's going to tell his parents
straight up I think he's gonna tell
Allison Auto straight up what happened
but he's not going to say that it was by
accident because why would you ever want
to give up some yeah you're weak and
then your dragon doesn't like you you
weren't even given a dragon you had to
like control this one and then only to
be told that like the dragon doesn't
even listen to you yeah he doesn't want
to know that and like uh if we if we
ascribe to the idea that these Dragon
Riders have like a psychic connection
with their dragon in a way it could I I
believe that vegar is like I don't care
what you're saying to me right now this
little dragon just blew fire on my face
I'm gonna teach it yeah right
but also in the back of ayman's head if
he's like man I just want to kill this
kid so bad right now well if vegar takes
that as a sign of like psychically
you're like oh this is what my writer
wants I'm gonna do it I get that but I I
that's the thing I think that he doesn't
have that connection I think vegar is
just so old and he's just like I've been
through writers yeah sure go ahead get
on my back but likely on my back this I
think more of the yeah I think more of
the thing to look at in this is the fact
that he can't control the oldest
strongest dragon and that is very
dangerous for the realm because what
happens when he the dragon is just like
you don't save your car is the dragon
blows an entire Army away yeah what if
the dragon eats one of the greens
dragons right just says
you told me the story I forget which
person it was and edit this out if this
is a square I don't think it is the
dragon that took the little girl all the
way away and she came back completely
there was uh this was like King
jaharis's uh
sister or like cousin or something like
that or niece my babies there's niece
she was uh Angry and she was kind of
rebellious she dropped she hopped on the
back of the black dread was dead now uh
and was gone for like a year and
everyone's like oh she stole it but when
she came back she was like burnt up and
had like creatures living inside of her
and like was burning from the inside and
basically died yeah they think Valerian
took her to like uh a Valeria where
there's like all sorts of weird
creatures stuff that's what I'm thinking
I'm like vegar eventually is may not
just listen yeah beggar just not gonna
listen take off um and unless someone
kills the dragon which is possible yeah
a vegar might just be like I'm gonna be
Reckless and be a random dragon wherever
I want uh it's also Keen to point out
that this is probably the first person
that England is killed oh yeah Eamon
hasn't really taken a life yet and he's
a he's a big guy he's got a lot of
Bravada he's ready to fight he's ready
to throw fists he hasn't killed someone
yet as far as we know so this is a big
deal I mean technically he didn't really
do this like like the dragon did it with
them but he set these events in motion
he didn't have to follow uh uh Luke so
this is totally his fault I even if the
dragons do this on their own like you
set this in motion I also think you have
to be like which is probably not true
but just like fully blooded Targaryen
for your dragon to really listen well
but according to viserys like that's not
even true it's not everyone could write
a joke anyone can ride a dragon have set
this idea that they have this power no I
believe that and I believe that but it's
just like okay it's not listening to
Eamon right and it's not listening to
Luke and we just got to keep watching it
maybe just heiress Dragon will be like
close enough because they're older but
it's still like so far from what I've
seen if you are not 100 I guess well no
because Emma wasn't really Emma wasn't a
Targaryen uh she was part Targaryen she
was part Target so okay so it's also the
daughter of a Baratheon I believe so
only it only seems like the dragons
really do listen to Damon and rhinera
and because I'm like I have not seen how
Helene is with her Dragon I haven't seen
how aegons with his Dragon there's the
younger idea that back on Old Valeria
right there was a lot of magic involved
that they don't seem to do anymore you
know Damon and raniera had like an old
school Valerian wedding with a little
blood magic stuff but like we don't see
as much as the blood magic you know uh
visares brought up blood majors and
stuff on Old Valeria how they would help
control the dragons and it's like the
magic is gone and now it's just like
straight it's just uh you use a little
high Valerian a little brute force and
the Dre you ride the dragon and there
maybe is this connection but in theory
anyone could do it so I don't know have
we not seen baby aegon yet uh is baby
aegon still a baby baby aegon it's
probably still a baby not much time has
passed since they showed it to viserys
like it's still pretty much a baby and
when I say baby aegon because there's
three aegons
Damon's child aegon uh
yes okay uh my next question for you
Jessica why did viserys never share A
Song of Ice and Fire with his bro Damon
because his bro was never meant to be
king it was never meant to rule well you
don't think this is an important thing
to tell your brother I think you tell
the people a that you trust which he
gives right not to trust Damon and then
um whoever is going to be next in line
to take the throne and that's why he
never told Allison but I think that's
why he told renera because he was like
you're going to be the next enthroned
you need to know how to take care of a
kingdom and then and also keep this in
mind and how have you think about the
way viserys the peaceful chose to rule
uh which is showing itself now peace in
the realm and his he's a dreamer and he
believes in these dreams and he's like I
have to keep this piece because it's my
job to prepare the realm for this this
Danger from the north that is coming and
it could come any day now we know it
doesn't happen for another like 150
years but like to him it's gonna come
right now and that's how Ranier
approaches this whole situation right
she's like I have to make sure that my
sons are ready
this this could happen any day now and
that's also why she's hesitant to jump
into a war right now 100 and Damon's
like come on let's go let's go let's go
uh I also think it's telling that you
know viserys never made Damon hand which
is what Damon wanted more than anything
but viserys knew that Damon was like
hot-headed yeah had a temper yeah it was
ready to fly up the handle and I'm sure
during his youth viserys is always going
to his brother like damn man I had
another dream and that's what's gonna
happen and Damon's like I don't want
your poor tens and your visions and your
Omens I want to get out there and fight
and viserys is like oh I can't trust oh
Damien with these problems and maybe
even viserys told David about the Song
of Ice and Fire and David doesn't even
remember he's like ah just another one
of those dumb dreams because he did say
that he was like my brother was a liar
like he didn't believe in the dragons he
believed in this and I thought it was
foolish he thought it was a waste of
time and he watched his brother waste
away you know he thinks he was
immediately like my brother was killed
yeah and you know back when when he saw
him last he was like he's he it was kind
of intuitive that he he thought he was
being poisoned not just the milk of the
poppy but like we talked about this a
couple weeks ago like was there
something else in this tea today they
thought he thought he was they were
slowly poisoning his brother he always
just wanted to be with his brother to
protect his brother and to keep the
targaryens in charge you know he looks
at that crown and he sees that Dragon
sigil he's like we've got to use these
dragons we've got to do this now let's
go to Harren Hall let's surround King's
Landing let's burn them which I'm uh
horrible horrible that Luke died I love
Luke right but like is now a clear
indication like having a lot of dragons
doesn't mean [ __ ] right now like vegar
ripped through right literally didn't
even finish the bite in the dragon
that's how big Veigar is and when
they're like because everyone's like
well we have more dragons and I'm like
yeah but they have Veigar yeah vegar
eats dragons this baby dragon cannot eat
thank God I don't want to rule over Ash
and Bone like yeah
what's the point because you know make
our make our other makeover the cruel
like he used his dragons all the time
and it didn't work you know like
everyone hated it everyone yeah and
that's why I was nervous about ratings
but it seems like no one really cares
anymore when rainy's broke through the
floor I was like more reason for the
small folk to be afraid of I mean
they're not gonna forget that day I
wouldn't I'd be like I'm never gonna
vote for another Targaryen because I
don't want these dragons tripping
through my oh sorry sorry I forgot I
forgot
oh you precious so much I forgot we
didn't get to vote you can vote to have
your head on a spike that's what you can
vote for all right
please yeah
yeah that moment when Damon
she's kind of like you don't know about
the song of my Sapphire he's like oh
don't start with I was also like
oh this is already kind of telling just
serious about it she's like prepping him
like hey we need to I'm in charge we
need to stay in charge there's Destiny
there's important things we have to do
to keep this realm in check so
you got to get with it you should get
with it but Damon is left out of the
loop uh okay Jessica I got another
question for you here does renira does
renira really have all these dragons
under her control that as Damon claims
as we talk about these dragons they
don't really listen you know he points
out Damon points out that the greens
have like three adult dragons yeah you
know they obviously have vagar which is
a big one you know they've got Sunfire
who is uh aegon's dragon Helena's got a
dragon so they got a few adult dragons
and they got like a baby one on the way
right but the blacks as he points out
they they've got Cyrax they've got
cracksis they got melees even though
initially renise is like well you don't
have melees yet I love when they kept
adding her and she kept being like she
kept giving these awkward like
uh yeah we'll get back to that we'll
Circle back to that one when where yeah
they've got ver Max which is uh just
Sarah's Dragon they had air X R.I.P uh
tyraxis who is the dragon for Joffrey
which you haven't seen yet and Bayless
got Moon Dancer adorable little Moon tin
so don't roll your eyes
he starts listening off the unclaimed
ones remember Reina Bayless twin sister
does not have one her eyes lit up a
little bit she's like unclaimed dragons
you saying uh so see smoke as we pointed
out it's still back at drift mark That's
laners or Dragon Verma Thor who it looks
like that's Joe Harris's Dragon he's the
big dog that's who Damon's gonna go try
to get we have Silverwing now this was
Queen Alison's dragon that was just Joe
Harris's sister wife uh so another old
Dragon powerful has been flying around
and then he brings up three wild dragons
yeah uh hanging out uh and then a score
incubating is what he said yeah we have
a score incubating yeah he's been taking
uh so do they really have this Dragon
power or is this like Dan was kind of
like overplaying his hand I mean renero
points out that these are untested yeah
battle dragons I think
um going back to what I said earlier
about the targaryens and I think like
pure bloods oh but I think like
rhaenyra spent a lot of time with her
Dragon growing up it was like her and
her Dragon she was like I'm gonna ride
this [ __ ] I'm gonna go hang out with my
dragons and I think she actively was
like Damon uh was learning more about
dragons and being like this is our
family saying this is it and I think we
need to remember like when the kids were
training with the dragons none of them
were really like
in it with the dragon they were just
like yeah whatever here's my high
Valerian like I'm trying but like
Rainier and Damon take that [ __ ] to
heart so I think raynera will be able to
go to like even the baby dragons and be
able to be like and like it will like
connect with her okay because she's just
been with it since birth like her and
Damon have always been doing this with
Dragons viserys wasn't so it's like they
have a different pool than the children
probably do and they learn differently
than the children do they were more in
it than the children are it's
interesting because we saw jacaris kind
of struggling with high Valerian a
couple episodes ago so it's like you
have that side of it but then you also
show like Eamonn you know when he's on
vegar and he's losing control he's
saying in English and high valarian
listen to me and it's almost like is
Allison not as good at teaching the high
Valerian two words Targaryen kids
having trouble with her half strong kids
yes getting so it's like they're both
nice but also great well-equipped
already I think the fact is like and
also amen open both their eyes guys see
you dummy you weren't you didn't get a
dragon you didn't connect with a dragon
what makes you think that you can just
grab one dude especially like the oldest
strongest dragon so it's like not even
not even having the most temperamental
Dragon it's just like there might be a
reason why you didn't connect with a
dragon a dragon and hatch for you you
don't connect you get a pig you get a
pink dread you get the pink dread baby
all right so I I just think
he has a lot they they're gonna the
greens are so in so much trouble
dragon game real quick
Otto is literally like some hatching
that we don't know about they don't and
the second the second episode
or the first episode second season will
be Auto literally having to migrate
Otto will be like I don't know
who am I his grandkids am I gonna throw
fish who do I hit first you're about to
see both hands of the king also it's
like
okay I can't spoil anything
next question Jessica are raniera and
Damon still a team or are their goals
two different absolutely not I think
this was kind of like that joke was was
intense it was a lot and I think it
really showed Rainier like okay this
guy's always going to be a problem and
like he's constantly not listening to
her this episode constantly pushing his
way of doing things you know he never
really wanted the Iron Throne right but
he just wanted to rule with his brother
he kind of wanted to have that power and
here he's like I don't need to be the
you can be the queen you're the queen
you're the queen honey but I'm gonna
push my arms around I'm gonna do it
we're gonna take over and he hates IO I
mean he cannot wait to kill Otto he
pulls his sword out on that bridge he's
like let's go let's go on this bridge
right now
but he she won't let him have it and I I
think this is this gonna just push them
further apart 100 this is the start of
something I mean the fact that he
ignored her cries 400 when she's she did
the same freaking thing to his right I
mean he killed his wife he killed his
first wife he ignored the second one
well he didn't ignore it he didn't say
okay
no but she is on the ground freaking
beceros went to Emma and was like yeah
like he he literally was just like she's
screaming a lot
screaming a lot and I've been stabbed so
I know how it feels
um he's like comparing the two yeah
either way I 100 this is the downfall
and I also if it wasn't the downfall I'd
be shook uh because again I need to
remember and I think a lot of people do
that Damon is not a good character right
he is a bad guy and he does a lot of bad
things out of just his own selfishness
and I think this is the start of it of
him being like yeah why the hell is she
ruling and also like the the freaking
math doesn't add up for him to be okay
with renera taking the throne you know
like he's like I'm older I've worked
under my brother I've seen everything
I've done more than you have I've gone
to War I should be the one putting in
orders yeah I think he he doesn't want
to wear the crown but he wants to be in
charge I think he wants to do what
Otto's doing for Alice right and it's
just like renera like Damon are very
driven and so that I think it's just
gonna be temperamental and they're gonna
start to hate each other I mean speaking
of those crowns this is a little side
question how do they always fit
perfectly I want one I want one I
thought about it last episode when they
go to put the conqueror's crown on aegon
I was like do you think they tested
first did you it just doesn't did you
not make it that far in the book were
there all their heads are the same size
everyone's got the same time
this just came off just saris's uh head
which was maybe falling apart maybe lost
in the air at some point I don't know or
viserys well I think and he puts it so
perfectly on our head I'm like how do
these crowns just fit everything
targaryens not only do they can they
drink dragons they all have the same
sizes their skulls are all the same
unless it's super inbred then it's kind
of weird I I just think that like Damon
too I to them kind of going in different
directions now I think it's shown that
he doesn't like it when someone gets the
upper hand on 100 it really offends him
you know winter Kristen Cole like
unseated him in the jousting he and like
gave him a hand afterwards he bats it
away he's like I want your help I want
people's help uh when you know him and
Ranier have their wild night on the town
and she's like into it he's like I'm not
into it anymore can't get it up I'm out
of here bye her at that fireplace scene
where he chokes her out or doesn't choke
her out with chokes her and she's like
you don't know about this vision and she
makes a little smirk I think right then
that's what I'm done with that's when
the tables don't turn you're not better
than me girl I genuinely was like I was
like roast him I said roast him this guy
I said roast him mother she's a roast
this guy
um speaking of dreamers viserys being a
dreamer there was an interesting moment
during uh uh rhaenyra's kind of labor
pains uh and you know uh
uh Damon is addressing the the
kingsguard and testing the dragon she
has these visions of a dragon real
quickly they kind of pop into her head a
snarling Dragon a mouth open is is
rhaenyra a dreamer does is she a dreamer
herself too she is a dragon rider we
know that she's a competent Dragon Rider
but is she also maybe a dreamer was this
a vision that she was having what did
you take to mean of these like dragons I
thought I immediately and this is just
immediately watching I didn't think
twice about it I immediately thought it
was her seeing the baby's dragon in the
future
yeah the baby that she's having right
now I think it was the baby's Dragon but
not because the baby dragon is still in
the egg I think it's like later we know
you know uh Damon pointed out we've got
some eggs incubating maybe the egg that
I think that's that idea that this was
that Dragon yeah that was that dragon's
baby because if you did mention a
briefly that like maybe they since they
have that it's like good connection yeah
the connection maybe her Dragon felt her
pain and I was like well what if the
baby what
and it was crying out yeah I mentioned
to you earlier like I wondered if this
because it was kind of golden cyrex is
kind of golden I wonder if Cyrax was
feeling her pain
I'd be so mad wherever Cyrax was I was
also thinking we know that aegon has a
dragon called Sunfire which is described
as like a very beautiful golden dragon
was this Sunfire she was seeing was she
seeing aegon's Dragon for some weird
reason uh I don't know I was this like a
dream or a vision I think it was very
interesting thing I like the idea that
this is like her starting once her
father died it's just like now it's all
starting that she's yeah I think she's
so tuned into the world I think she's
the ultimate Targaryen I think she is
like the most Supreme Targaryen there
can be because not only is she possibly
a dreamer she also is holds an army and
she can probably control a lot of
dragons right right so I'm just like
this is the embodiment of the targaryens
so I think she is a dreamer and I think
she'll get these Visions when she's
maybe in like
over the barrier of pain like because
it's like not only a physically it's
emotional I mean this episode she loses
her father Yes she loses two children oh
God she loses her husband maybe like the
alliance she has with her husband
whatever he said I think she's noticing
it and I love that for her I'm like yeah
yeah she lost your alcohol husband is a
piece and her claim to the throne has
been lost or at least it feels like just
imagine the one day in your life where
it felt like everything fell apart and
then 10 more times because not only did
she lose everything it's all happy after
this point it's all happy stories after
the Sunday after the Sunday night one
last question before we get out of here
today Jessica did Allison make Rainier a
good faith offer when through Otto here
when Otto shows up okay I mean it's a
good it's not a bad deal oh my children
she's like your your son Luke he can
still be lord of the tides your your
other son he'll have a place in the
court you you can have Dragonstone it'll
be all yours uh all these you know
you're trying to come to the court they
can beat and things like that all safe
place and I I think it was interesting
that page that she's given we saw this
in the like it was episode recap at the
beginning is what she ripped out of the
book you know when they were friends
Allison kept this this whole time and we
saw in episode eight at the dinner
before viserys died like there was that
glimmer of like we can still be friends
we still care about each other you know
this is very different from the book
this kind of relationship that they have
do you and we know that Allison made
Moves last week to protect Rainier and
her family yeah do you think that this
was was a good faith offer that Allison
was really trying to be like listen I
stole the crown from you but we can
settle this we can squash the beef no
one can live on no and yes because I
think
Otto stole that page out of her room I
don't think she gave Otto
oh I can stand up run around the room
I love that idea I don't think I don't
think she gave that to him I don't think
she was like here she'll listen to you
this because the mo the biggest insult
you can give is giving Damon's kids the
possibility to be a cup Bearer and Sir
yeah that was her learning this isn't
learning through aegon and amen that is
the biggest insult and also Rainer was a
cup Bearer because she was a woman so
it's like one man could be man could be
cupboard they can't they can but her
specifically the princess that was in
line to be heir to the thrill like to be
the throne yeah they were like well she
can learn by just she'll be around if
they were a man they would be sitting at
that point when she was a cup bear and
they were having issues she was like let
me hop on my dragon and go deal with it
and Coraline at the time was like yeah
listen to this but the rest of them are
like let's go and the rest of them are
like no so when her kids are like let's
hop on our dragons and go deal with it
and she's like yes they're like dead now
one of her kid is dead because of that
oh my God so it's almost like yeah they
were right uh but also it's so Otto I
think stole that page from uh from
Allison's room and was like remember you
guys are best friends because he even
brought that up to Allison was like are
you acting like this because you guys
were friends when you were children yeah
like we don't have time for that and
also I think like I think Allison is
more uh more
thing about her children which is nice
because I wouldn't but I think she's
thinking about her children first and
she's genuinely like yeah I think this
is the best offer we can offer her but
it's still like you think
they were going to be nice to the just
Sarah's on the council they were going
to treat him like Lord beesberry and
Chris and Cole would have killed him
yeah we've seen Game of Thrones right
when Cersei is able to use the Stark kid
yeah in her Court yeah exactly like the
were you were hostages there is no good
that would have came about that was not
good faith it was like Allison was like
this is probably the best offer we can
give and maybe she'll believe that I'll
watch over them but at the end of the
day the people in that room would have
been Otto and aegon which would not have
been good is like yeah we'll go along
with this and as soon as I get these
kids on the boat I'm going to cook yeah
I'm gonna cut some throats too so I
think he was just trying so hard to like
appease to that like young girl that was
best friends with his daughter and being
like see you're controlled by emotion
and she was like no I'm not yeah [ __ ]
idiot I mean I think you know Allison
doesn't want to kill them but I think at
the end of the day she would agree I
can't wait she'll be Whittle down
because she knows how dangerous all this
is I think she well okay so she might
not like aegon and she is she
episode one of the second season you
will see she does not love Amon anymore
but she loves Helena yeah and I think
that she recognizes like you killed her
son right that is like killing my baby
yeah and this is all we have she's gonna
come back and kill us rightfully so like
rightfully so she's gonna be like you
better hope
vegar can eat uh 12 other dragons yeah
because they are gonna [ __ ] they're
gonna come for us now ah what an episode
okay Jessica we gotta get out of here
but before we do we gotta do our final
power rankings for the season who at the
end of the season has gained the most
power in your eyes go
foreign
ER because we don't know what the
message is for the other two people are
we don't know uh because they went to
the Baratheon but they didn't we don't
know the Starks and we don't know how
the Aaron house Aaron yeah responded and
we don't know this starts I mean we know
this starts they're good to win they're
good people but still we don't know we
don't know for sure we don't know in
this series and I'm going off of you
just one became a kinslayer right and
one is dead and that one that died do
you think Rainier looks good here looks
so good it looks so good for her if
people find out which they've already
found out so it's like
whoo and then also they still got they
got the tides they got the ties now
yeah so it's like what they got the
Lannister
that everyone hates yeah everybody
freaking hates they got the Lannisters
the Lancers don't like the targaryens
for sure uh I'm gonna play devil's
advocate here Jessica I'm gonna say that
the greens and Allison gain the most
power of this episode because I think
much like you're saying that whole
situation what am I can come back and
say is like yo we we've crowned we've
crowned our King we got Agonist King and
these targaryens they always be playing
right they they brought this Dragon to
Storm's end and I we had to protect
Storm's end so our Dragon Vega protected
us from these evil dragons you saw how
evil these dragons are they came up
through the boards they killed a bunch
of small but you're driving this is
scariest looking one yes but it saved us
from these dragons that are coming
they're gonna send more dragons until
Vegas starts eating the small folk out
of fun look we turn the Dragon green on
our Center oh you're safe now the the
high tower don't worry so I think
Allison's still in a position of power
here I think Otto's got a good point the
whole Kingdom saw this kid crown and
we're near is going to look she's gonna
look crazy coming after it I think and I
think and they have the baratheons on
their side they've got the Lannisters on
their side they obviously I think High
Towers I think it comes down to like
Pete the people and being like Who you
gonna believe or not who you're gonna
believe but who are you excited we gotta
vote for baby nobody stop it a baby
dying a baby dying or a dragon I mean
baby babies die a lot of this
you're the maesters
the new maze to the black guy's fine but
the old one was like he was the one that
was not changing everything I don't I
don't like it I don't trust any mason I
like them my sister was also like let's
get Lord beesberry's body out of here
like and they were like no and he was
like okay what is he gonna do my problem
you're a maester maesters are only there
to dirty up their fingers and Shove It
And Shove It get the leeches okay who
lost the most power of this episode are
we gonna be on opposite side I think we
are because I I I think it's well
yeah no I'll say Allison I'm gonna say
Allison specifically Allison because she
doesn't have any power clearly uh it's
aegon and Otto okay and oh because she's
just kind of like she's just the wife uh
now she's or she's just the queen
without a husband without a king right
so it's like it's like imagine Cersei
without any power because it's like she
her son's not gonna listen to her her
Auto's not listening to her all she has
left is like Helena after Eamon just
killed her best friend her stepdaughter
her daughter uh son so it's like what
does she have yeah what does she have
nothing she's just oh she has the guy
that jerks off the feet uh hilarious the
wheels are in motion now and she's just
kind of saying yeah what is Larry's
gonna do cut off a dragon burn some more
people that's for sure and they're gonna
catch on they go back it has to be this
I'm gonna I'm gonna argue here that I
think rainey's and Corliss lost the most
power this episode they kind of just
they've they've teamed up with with
Rainier and the Gang and they're like
let's go you know of course it's like
let's retired let's get out of here and
renice is like no we can't we got
grandkids to worry about we have to keep
fighting and I think it's gonna be uh I
think they've they're in a powerful
position but they've they've given up
the most agency because their decision
was the most important now that they've
made that decision I think you know I
feel it the the Dyess cast and the game
will play out as it plays out
I don't think there's there's nothing
they can do to stop right now no that's
like I think that's I've always thought
they've lost power because I mean yeah
they've been slowly losing power
literally
I'm just waiting for the girls to die at
this point and then maybe not gonna be a
lot of Barbarians left much longer yeah
yeah they're gonna be the first are they
the first house that goes uh I don't I
don't know for sure I'd have to check
out my notes on that one what's the
first house that goes let's go to the
houses that disappear over time yeah
they just go I guess out of the
important houses which one goes first I
don't know uh we'll have to wait for
season two to find out uh that's it for
this episode of big question presents
talking dragons uh we're gonna have one
more episode of this special edition of
big question uh presents talking dragons
to give our final thoughts on season one
of House of the dragon and the biggest
questions that remain as we wait for
season two so uh throw your questions in
the comments of this episode uh hit us
up on Twitter let us know what your big
questions are or your thoughts for this
whole season of House of the dragon and
we'll go through those next week before
we get back to doing some regular big
question here on the channel which might
look a little different than you
remember but we'll still be lots of fun
uh and next week Jessica we might even
do a little talk and Toki next week oh
God I haven't finished rings of power
finish it up and we'll talk about that a
little bit uh last week before we say
goodbye to our fantasy shows for now
don't forget to check out our mini great
merch options over at New
rockstarsmerch.com follow Jessica at
Lulu underscore Commons follow me at
grin and Barrack make sure you subscribe
to big question and new rockstars
wherever you watch us or listen to us uh
subscribe to new rockstars on all our
social channels thanks for watching us
today R.I.P uh our boy Luke one more
time for him
[Music]
foreign
[Music]